peu
[Musique]
à
apple brady watson menacer et ariane
tels les shorts brouillard pour
éclaircir les idées
oddsson
l' aventure papa la porte
[Musique]
en tandem
non c'est madame oleson qui est à notre
sol il ya une jeune fille ravissante qui
désirent vouloir être la rentrée
[Musique]
bis marie laure stable d'aristide
moiselle
[Musique]
ravie de faire votre connaissance
asseyez vous je vous en prie je suppose
que que le soin vous travaillez assez
tard et que vous exercez un métier
sédentaires oui comment ils seriez pas
venu à cette heure ci est incertain plie
de votre jus que je vois que vous
travaillez à 6 vous êtes dans
l'enseignement oui je suis institutrice
c'est l'évidence regardez vos mains vous
avez de l'encré rouge au bout des doigts
écoutez on smith mort cela n'est pas
venu pour vous lui fassiez votre petit
numéro d'acteur watson mandat séparables
je vous écoute
bon si vous voulais m'excuser je vous en
prie rester je suis venu vous voir sur
les conseils de monsieur frobisher il
vous est très reconnaissants de l'avoir
tiré d'embarras ye capte au buteur
on se tirait une petite affaire tout
simple messieurs holmes mon père a
disparu
il y a longtemps 3 1 est depuis trois
ans vous n'avez rien fait pour le
retrouver mais j'ai tout essayé
la police l'armée il est bien tard mais
je ne pus renoncé je conserve un espoir
dans quelles circonstances votre père at
il disparu
mon père était capitaine il servait aux
indes et appartenait à l'état major du
pénitencier des îles andaman
il m'avait mis en pension dans une
institution en écosse il y a trois ans
mon père m'a écrit pour me dire qu'il
avait bien réfléchi et qu'il avait
l'intention de rentrer en angleterre
définitivement et dans cette lettre ils
me demandaient de le rejoindre à l'hôtel
astor le 11 janvier
et puis quand j'y suis allé on m'a dit
que qu'il venait de sortir
il n'a jamais reparu étrange votre père
a sans doute laissé dans sa chambre des
bagages ou quelque chose
ses bagages il ne contenait rien de
particulier sauf ceux ci
[Applaudissements]
piette fabrication indienne
bien sûr quand des filles quatre croix
ça c'est grossier avec quatre signatures
différents le ciné 4 akbar sundaram
hached
ce sont des noix n'y a je n'atteins
semoule 3 à douille et en anglais
sexe de ce plan
il va sûrement désigner un lieu un
endroit que je trouve quelque chose
parfaitement raison de garder ce
document remis ce morceau je vais
étudier le problème je vous préviendrai
dès que j'aurai de découvrir quelque
chose alors voir mademoiselle je vous
raconte pas une miss moss times
allez vraiment charmante délicieuse qui
sa team is more stone bien sûr pas
remarqué watson soyez gentil d'aller
nous chercher un fiacre et où allons
nous j'ai le colonel choletais à
pondichéry lodge un livre extrêmement
intéressant cet annuaire de l'armée
anglaise car il vient de m'apprendre
comores cela n'était pendant dix ans
l'adjoint du commandant de la place un
certain colonel solo lequel shelton a
pris sa retraite il ya environ quatre
ans tim morse talent rare 30 en
angleterre avait du plaisir à quelqu'un
c'était de là ça ne pouvait être qu
elles sont le fichier supérieur
[Musique]
il n'y a personne ici
allez dire au colonel schill tôt que
sherlock holmes voudrait lui parler
personne ne peut plus parler au colonel
il est mort il ya longtemps
deux ans et demi monsieur voulez-vous me
faire l'honneur de d'accepter ces trois
livres
je suppose que vous connaissiez le
colonel depuis longtemps et qu'il était
satisfait de vous vous étiez son
ordonnance sans doute je l'étais dix ans
alors vous devez connaître d'autres
officiers de son état major
je n'avais affaires console colonel
choletais le lieutenant brown vous le
connaissiez il n'appartenait pas au
régiment et le majeur le dr smith
j'ai une bonne santé et le capitaine
morson monstre je regrette je connais
pas
essayez de vous souvenir je sais qu'il
est venu dans cette maison
il y environ trois ans je vous répète
que je ne sais pas de qui vous parlez
alors gardez votre sérénité orientale je
n'ai pas le temps de faire la causette
excusez moi bonne nuit
[Musique]
regardez
ça a été retournés de fond en comble ce
n'était sûrement pas pour y planter des
roses étrange demeure je commence à
douter que votre jeune ami quel jeune
ami j'avais l'impression que vous vous
intéressiez beaucoup à miss mort stone
elle ne m'a pas fait l'honneur de
m'accorder son amitié point fort elle
n'aura jamais plus on perd mon cher
watson
c'est à dire a menti morse talent est
bien venu ici il ya trois ans elle n'en
est jamais repartie suivez mots bien il
ya trois ans le capitaine mort stone
disparaît et six mois plus tard le
colonel chômeurs bien nous avons
commises morton a trouvé les papiers et
un plan la fois je ne vois pas du tout
c'est pourtant simple château doute
avoir des héritiers au mieux votre
théorie expliquerait aussi de signer car
j'ai mon idée là dessus
alors si je comprends bien cette affaire
est terminée elle commence une passion
pas pour voir si vite mademoiselle vous
voulez dire nous n'espérions pas j'ai
reçu ce matin une étrange colis il est
arrivé par la poste
il contenait une perle c'est le
troisième que je reçois
elle est magnifique pourquoi ne
l'avez-vous rien dit lors de votre
première visite bien je ne sais pas
toujours parlement sur l'expéditeur
quelques admirateurs inconnu non ce
n'est pas un admirateur et pourquoi pas
quel dommage que vous n'ayez pas garder
les emballages et voici au vous êtes
décidément d'une aide précieuse et ce
n'est pas tout avec le col il y avait
une lettre l'enveloppent aussi merci on
l'a mise à la poste à londres
la marque d'un pouce
celui du facteur
papier de qualité même écriture que sur
les paquets
écriture également qu'entre fait trouvez
vous ce soir à 10 heures au coin de mary
ball et old band corde il va de votre
intérêt vous ne le regretterez pas les
perles doit vous inciter à accepter ce
rendez vous il faut y aller
[Musique]
on
que voulez vous je suis sherlock holmes
ou des détectives et vous êtes le fils
du colonel choletais en ses deux fils
nous laissait rien à vous dire j'ai
rendez vous avec mademoiselle mort stade
elle est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mademoiselle je sais que vous avez été
victime d'une grande injustice mais elle
sera réparée vous avez droit à la moitié
d'un trésor que mon frère et moi avons
découvert après de longues recherches
il ya trois ans votre père at il reçu la
visite du capitaine mort ce talent je
vous en prie ne m'embrouiller pas avec
vos questions c'est déjà assez difficile
comme ça si je ne commence pas par le
début voilà lorsque notre père est
rentré des indes c'était un autre il
avait tellement changé que nous n'avons
pas reconnu les fièvres sans doute
l'avait miné il était devenu sauvage
irritable toujours nerveux sursaute au
moindre bruit
[Musique]
on aurait dit qu'il avait peur de tout
il ne voulait plus voir personne sauf
mon frère et moi et le capitaine mort
stone il n'en a jamais parlé mais je
sais que mort cela n'est venu une fois à
pondichéry deutsch on l'avait vu ce jour
là non tout juste aperçu je vais surtout
entendu
[Musique]
cya
c'est moi qui vous dit c'est pas vous la
connaissez vous êtes sûr que c'était
mort ça puisque nous l'avions vu arriver
[Musique]
n'y va pas
et après rien je n'ai plus jamais
entendu parler du capitaine manceau
vous l'avez quand même vu sortir de la
maison ce jour là non il a dû passer par
la porte fenêtre du jardin une
possibilité continuer mon père venait de
jour en jour plus nerveux il nous a
finalement avoué que sa vie était en
danger et qu'il se sentait traquée par
un homme à la jambe de bois
[Musique]
c'est sûr le facteur qu'il avait tiré ce
facteur est il un homme de couleur
norman écossais persuadé que sa fin
était proche
mon père rédigea son testament c'était
presque une confession avarice et par
esprit de lucre je reconnais avoir privé
la fille du capitaine mort stan de la
moitié d'un fabuleux trésor de diamants
et de pierres précieuses que j'avais
rapporté des indes et qui me revenait de
plein droit
je n'ai pas jusqu'ici toucher à cette
fortune et je désire que mes deux fils
ray parlour causés à la fille de mon ami
le coffre contenant les diamants et
caché à pondichéry lodge dans le il a un
malaise va appeler le médecin je vais
chercher le plaquant des thèmes
[Applaudissements]
le signe des quatre n'est ce pas oui
mais comment savez-vous et le trésor
eh bien nous avons cherché procès vous
avez retourné le jardin de fond en
comble les envois de perles
c'était une petite compensation mais
nous avons retrouvé le coffre de
diamants et mon frère et moi allons tout
régler nous respecterons les dernières
volontés notre père c'est la moindre des
choses
vous allez devenir riche miss portman il
faut que vous voyez mon frère dès ce
soir je voudrais rentrer je défendrai
vos intérêts compter sur moi mon cher
watson l'a raccompagné mademoiselle et
venez nous rejoindre
il comprend
[Musique]
ou a bien pu passer à la trappe et avait
toute confiance en lui pourquoi n'y at
il pas de lumière
bartolomé devrait être ici parce nommé
par tono me répond ah ouais tu monsieur
je ne suis pas très rassuré il est
arrivé quelque chose à mon frère
madame vers stones ou et vous
qu'avez-vous qu'y at il
pourquoi êtes vous là tout seul dans le
noir
dites le moi j'ai eu peur horrible
monsieur tabou ni hao commencé à lui
aussi oui c'est comme monsieur bartolo
mais je ne sais pas ce qui lui est
arrivé vers une ruelle car il est allé
sans fermer à clé dans sa chambre il
n'en est pas encore sorti ouais ça
chambre voilée
[Musique]
la deuxième porte
la clé de la série a attiré moins
[Musique]
watson pitt et des mois laissez moi
faire
il est mort sans aucun doute vous étiez
jumeaux
le signe des 4
je leur ai juré attention cette flèche
et sûrement un polonais
décidément
le mystère s'épaissit de plus en plus
retrouver
je ne suis pas de votre avis je crois
plutôt qu'il s'éclaircit encore quelques
détails à vérifier et je tiendrai tous
les fils de l'énigme les diamants ont
disparu tout le coffre était cachée là
au juste sous le toit
nous l'avions descendu mon frère et moi
mon dieu c'est moi qui ai vu mon frère
ni vent pour la dernière ça n'arrive pas
grand sens ici la police va s'en mêler
et c'est moi qui seraient inculpées ces
216 que je vous aurais fait venir
est-ce que j'aurais pris contact avec
miss personnes comme on leur expliquait
c'est en perdre la tête à ça de mon
propre
vous n'avez aucune raison d'avoir peur
monsieur choletais suivez mon conseil
aller au commissariat
dites-leur simplement ce qui s'est passé
et nous attendons votre retour dans
cette pièce
si jamais j'en reviens à environ une
demi heure devant nous profitons-en
l'affairé risque de présenter certaines
complications bien qu'elles paraissent
toutes simples pour l'instant simple du
allemand suivez moi comment l'assassin
est il entré dans la place la porte elle
était fermée à clé de l'intérieur les
fenêtres
fermée de l'intérieur
châssis solide pas de trace d'effraction
et pourtant quelqu'un est andrei
regarder l'empreinte d'un pied de la bo
et nous retrouvons l'empreinte là et là
il emprunte circulaire mais ce n'est pas
l'empreinte d'un pile c'est mieux c'est
l'empreinte d'un pilon l'homme dont le
colonel choletais avaient peur et qui
avait fini par le tuer aujourd'hui il a
eu le fils et les diamants beau doublé
moi je veux bien mais grimper là avec
une jambe de bois
et puis passé par une fenêtre fermée
c'est impossible si vous êtes seul
mais si vous avez un complice qui ouvre
la fenêtre de l'intérieur et qui vous
lance une corde solide et comment ce
complice est il venu lui est reparti
avant car se trouve génial watson vous
fait des progrès fulgurants et comme at
il su qu'il y avait un trou au plafond
et bien parce qu'on le lui a dit
j'aimerais bien entretenir cinq minutes
avec le dénommé raveau
regardez ça watson la preuve qu
effectivement le complice est passée par
là regardez là haut c'est du caire ne
vous la voyez et de cette lucarne
pour parvenir au trou en faisant preuve
son tout petit vous ne prétendez tout de
même pas qu'un enfant est mêlé à cette
horrible histoire
souvenez vous de mon grand principe
quand vous avez éliminé toutes les
autres hypothèses restantes
aussi improbable que cela puisse
paraître est forcément la bonne
naturellement si on le met c'est le
premier arrivé sur les lieux du crime
heureusement qu'il ya encore une police
à qui on peut se fier en tout cas c'est
une sale affaire
cette fois ci nous allons nous en tenir
aux faits voyons ça de plus près alors
il paraît que la porte était fermée et
les deux fait aussi à secondes dit oui
mais il ya des traces de pas sur le
rebord vite que la fenêtre était fermé
les bas n'ont rien à voir dans
l'histoire on est venu laver les
carreaux c'est aussi simple que ça
d'ailleurs ce monsieur avoué qu'il était
dans cette pièce avec son frère hier
soir il l'a empoisonné
il a caché le magot et il a eu l'audace
de venir au commissariat en simulant
l'affolement dans l'espoir de se mettre
hors de cause
et pendant ce temps le cadavre craignant
sans doute de s'enrhumer s'élever à
fermer la porte et s'est recouché mais
mon cher monsieur ce sont des détails
qui n'ont aucune importance
permettez moi de vous faire profiter de
quelques détails assez significatif nous
avons trouvé une petite flèche
empoisonnée dans le cou de la victime
probablement du curragh il y avait aussi
cette cette feuille de papier portant le
signe des 4 elle était bien en évidence
sur la veste et du cadavre
bon c'est un vieux truc qui a beaucoup
servi non c'est absolument démentielle
tadeusz alto il est de mon devoir de
vous informer que désormais tout ce que
vous direz pourra être utilisé
contre vous au nom de la reine je vous
arrête pour homicide volontaire sur la
personne de votre frère ne vous
inquiétez pas outre mesure sur le dos je
vous promet d'apporter la preuve
irréfutable de votre innocence sergent
quant à vous mon cher l'estrade
je vais éclairer votre lanterne voilà
deux individus sont entrés ici l'un
d'eux s'appelle jonathan small il a une
jambe de bois draf réalité et ce qui ne
serait pas un manchot aussi est il autre
hamon l'autre c'est un être plutôt
indéfinissable voilà une indication fort
précieuse non j'avais mon coupable et
vous me permettrai de le garder nous
sommes maîtres du terrain alors
mettons-nous au travail
mon cher watson
maintenant que nous avons mis un peu
d'ordre dans tout ça essayons de nous
résumer la sphère commence dans un bagne
des îles andaman
il y en a quatre forçats d'où le signe
des 4
l'un d'eux est un unijambiste blanc
nommé ionatos maul mais pourquoi un
unijambiste
parce que c'est précisément lui
l'unijambiste que celle tornhout est
d'autre part nous force à purgeait une
peine pour un vol de diamants qu'ils
avaient pris la précaution de catch et
dans un lieu secret bien supposer que
supposer que small soudoie le commandant
en chef du pénitencier
le colonel choletais un officier
britannique vous officiez de sa majesté
peuvent aimer l'argent
le contact j'imagine va se faire par
l'intermédiaire de raho
selon l'offre de révéler la cachette du
13 heures et de le partager avec celle
tôt à condition bien sûr qu'on lui
permettent ensuite de s'évader cholot
d'hommes sont d'accord là-dessus notre
ami small dessine un plan celui que nous
connaissons et le fait parvenir à soltau
tout se passe comme prévu
salto récupère le trésor seulement ils
oublient les quatre fort ça il va
prendre sa retraite en angleterre là
dessus arrive mort stan le père de marie
là je ne vois pas ailleurs watson s'est
pourtant limpides le capitaine mort stan
et l'officier en second de choletais il
à découvrir toute la sphère il rentre en
angleterre exige une partie du butin et
le jour même disparaît sans laisser de
traces mais au bagne johnatan small
enfin réussi à s'évader
le voici de retour en angleterre il
surveille guette attend près par son
coût il ya quelques heures
il frappe mais il a besoin de quelqu'un
pour franchir un passage exigus vous
devinez la suite
écoutez moi bien watson j'ai découvert
un livre fort intéressant sur le taux se
passionnait pour les ouvrages
d'ethnologie
on sait que les aborigènes vivant aux
îles andaman forme sans doute la race la
plus petite au monde
c'est une race farouche et impitoyable
ils ont dû la barre en 6 2
ils sont la terreur des naufragés ils
les tuent à l'aide de fléchettes
empoisonnées
venez voir les voir comme ils sont
jolies
si l'étrange complice ressemble à ce
petit monstre et n'ira pas loin
je n'en suis pas si sûr ça fait déjà
trois ans que je la tan small est sombre
et son petit associé sont à londres et
circulent sans problème alors
il s'agit de savoir où peut bien se
cacher à naître aussi étrange dans une
cave
non il se cache dans un endroit où tout
le monde peut le voir
[Musique]
voilà
est ce que vous cherchez y'a rien à voir
aux menées soit qu'est ce que c'est
je cherche un unijambiste est un âge
c'est qu'il se cache ici une se cache
pas du tout je les ai encore vu tout à
l'heure
eh bien on me reverrait pas de si tôt
vous êtes un policier non un
philanthrope
[Musique]
les chiens ils sont partis ils ont
emmené toutes leurs affaires
exactement que je disais
regardez watson l'empreinte du pied de
notre petite amie au watson vite il est
plaisant c'est de small dont vous parlez
vous travaillez pour lui ouais 10 3
onglets répondait aux cashes attention
[Musique]
mais si vous
vous avez dit
l'homme à la jambe de bois je sais qu'il
va le retrouver qui t'habille
[Musique]
holtz est tout sûr que ce cher est
infaillible n'a pas perdu la trace une
seule allée chercher 100 quand la proche
[Musique]
[Rires]
le
[Musique]
échec complet ils ont pris la fuite sur
un des bateaux de monsieur smith
s'appelle toby et toi bien jack
dis moi qu'est ce qui te fera plaisir
aux aching rachid et vois rien qui te
fera encore plus plaisir
si des chiens qui peut le caresser
mais c'est tout petit galopin la
recevoir une raclée quand on perd ce
sera de retour
tu as de la chance qu'il soit sorti il
n'est pas là non dommage j'avais à lui
parler trop vous l'auriez vu y'a pas
plus d'une demi-heure
mais si c'est pour un bateau je suis là
c'est même très ennuyeux oui j'aurais
voulu jouer sur bateau à vapeur le
lawrence ho oui c'est cela leur aura
c'est le vieux bateau vert avec une
bordure jaune au nom l'arpa neuf tout en
noir avec des rêves rouge
ça m'ennuie qu'il ne m'ait pas attendu
qui ça vient
mon ami avec la jambe de bois ah oui
c'est même bien vous je crois qu'il est
parti avec mon mari
vous l'avez vu partie enfin je veux
m'occuper de mon gosse j'ai pas bien
remarqué mais je sais qu'il y avait deux
passagers et y allons nous faire
réfléchir
durant les quatre jours qui viennent
soixante bateaux quittent londres dans
60 directions différentes
et vous pensez que small partir avec
l'un d'eux en important trésor est à peu
près sûr police est incapable de passer
60 navires au crible mais mais mais
comment empêcher nos voisins d'en
marquer c'est élémentaire j'aurais dû y
penser je me mets à la place de semoule
et je me pose la question comment
dissimuler un bateau en le gardant en
permanence près appareillé à qui leur
est confiée
c'est simple un chantier de réparation
en leur demandant de d'effectuer une
petite modification à la coque ou au
moteur quelle merveilleuse cachette
n'ont toujours prêt à partir
oui mais des chantiers de réparation il
y en a tellement vous avez une façon
abstraite de voir les choses d'une façon
intellectuelle si je puis dire oui mais
le temps passe vous n'êtes pas
personnellement concerné et je sache
ici figurez-vous is more stade a droit à
sa part d'une immense fortune et tant
qu'il y aura une chance je me
consacrerai watson il m'arrive parfois
de bannir le ciel de n'avoir jamais été
amoureux il faut réussir aux mns votre
inactivité mes frais
aux pieds pas aux apparences
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on n'en ai pas les gens
comme ça et vous ne savez pas à quelle
heure il rentrera en ce moment c'est
plus difficile à prévoir que jamais
asseyez vous dans un petit whisky
l'estrade
puisque vous insistez mais un tout petit
s'il vous plaît je vais plus préparés
dois-je comprendre que vous avez besoin
de rawls besoin besoin
n'exagérons rien mais j'attends toujours
avec impatience comme monsieur holmes
nous indique les noms de ces coupables
je reconnais qu'avec ses méthodes et ses
théories lui arrive de réussir et même
de temps à autre de me gagner de vitesse
mais cette fois nous sommes deux à
patauger
pas pour longtemps je pense je crois que
nous avons un visiteur que voulez-vous
mon ami monsieur lorsqu'il est là je
veux parler à monsieur aulas planquer
m'batto amende et kyle smith et et les
types qui cherche sa ou son cachet mes
respects il ya que la jeunesse qui est
plaisante à regarder ça fera une
gentille petite femme et les mousses ça
devrait aller
croyez moi une minute mon brave vous
détenez des renseignements en fort
intéressant qui se sucrent et bien que
cela vous plaise ou pas je vous garde
jusqu'à l'arrivée de monsieur aux
inspecteurs l'estrade scotland yard
c'est un abus de pouvoir
mon cher l'estrade route vous savez que
vous pourriez faire un excellent acteur
remarqué que malgré votre déguisement
j'avais des doutes j'en suis sûr j'avoue
que j'aime s'y laisser prendre
avez vous lu la gazette il y a quelque
chose d'intéressant
ah oui on y chante vos louanges méritées
d'ailleurs écouter ça
là la mystérieuse affaire de pondichéry
launch il semble 15h extraordinaire et
voulu que l'inspecteur lestrade le
célèbre détective de scotland yard se
trouve à ce soir-là au commissariat du
quartier ses talents ses dons
d'observation
sa longue expérience d'analysé vous même
je ne veux pas mettre à la torture votre
modestie
à propos vous devez faire relâcher
immédiatement monsieur tadeusz alto et
mademoiselle berne stone
il possède d'excellents alibi lesquels
s'il vous plaît et bien si vous tenez à
le savoir
au moment du crime tu es les us étaient
avec moi dis attention
scott lanières ne met jamais ma parole
en doute la sphère est résolu miss mort
stan je sais où sont les diamants qui
vous reviennent les bandits ont trouvé
refuge dans un vieux hangar du quartier
de l'alma hausse
permettez maintenant tout ça ne regarde
plus que moi votre heure viendra mon
cher l'estrade pour l'instant je préfère
utiliser ma police personnel elle est
même déjà la rentrée les enfants rentrer
mes chers amis je vous présente mes
assistants les francs tireurs de baker
street
eh bien je viens avec la bonne au
couplet chef très bien aux rapports ça
fera trois xining et 6 pence frais de
transport d'accord mais à l'avenir un
seul viendra au rappeur jeudi 3 chili 1
2 3 j ligne et six panneaux seront à
présent écouter
je veux savoir dans quel chantier de
réparation se trouve leur aura le bateau
de monsieur smith jacques tu te postera
sur ton l'embarcadère pour voir si le
bateau revient
les autres se partageront les deux rives
de la tamise c'est compris allez-y
quand
paris
[Musique]
une femme
la championne tu as pété des regards les
hangars
[Musique]
le
où
[Musique]
pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
chantier macintosh qu'est 28 il apparaît
dans deux heures avec lamari allons-y
watson vital et prévenir les str ap
[Musique]
e
walkman sentinelle est à son poste
[Musique]
ça ne devrait pas tarder
et voilà elle fixe comme le diable
machine à bord tout
[Musique]
ont poussé les feux
frash aux abeilles pour trop vite
absolument y arriver chaque poussée à
jausiers
pousser la chaudière
[Musique]
vous allez avoir froid
non vous êtes gentil
[Musique]
merci
m
oh non trannoy je vous ordonne d'arrêter
votre bateau je vous somme d'arrêter
immédiatement
non vous ne pourrez jamais ce n'est pas
inquiète jean natale ce mot pas le cas
ici
l'étoile fust hannachi
et
b
attention
quelques centimètres près vous étiez
morte mais
[Musique]
moi monsieur je n'ai jamais voulu causer
du tort aux jo de salt au je vous le
jure c'est le nain qui l'a tué
oui le nain tonga qui était avec moi
c'est lui qui lui envoyait une fléchette
avec sas à baqem s'il faut une
dérouillée terrible m mal était déjà
fait et hao a alors vous savez tout
je l'avais mis dans le coup il
trahissait sur le taux depuis quatre ans
alors je me suis dit qu'ils étaient bien
capables de me doubler aussi jalton vous
a volé quand vous étiez au ban il ne
fallait pas lui révéler l'emplacement du
trésor avant qu'il vous est remis en
liberté au fait d'où venait ce trésor on
l'a volé un match il évoque un héritier
à sa mort et il n'est pas mort dans son
lit bail
on a payé assez cher moi les trois
indiens oui on a fait dix ans de
pénitencier
c'est bien assez connaissez le binder
andaman c'est l'enfer où est la clé du
coffre
et vous pensez que cela nous empêche ce
nouveau record
[Musique]
bon vous allez me dire où sont les
diamants ce trésor personne au monde
n'avait le droit d'y toucher vous
entendez en dehors de moi et des trois
indiens qui sont encore en train de
crever dans la fournaise du bagne c'est
pour eux autant que pour moi j'ai agi
j'ai été fidèle aussi des 4 c'était plus
simple d'envoyer le coffre tout entier
par le siba a été aussi plus simple pour
nous de le repêcher
[Musique]
watson voulez vous encore dire miss mars
chez elle
elle a eu assez l'émotion journée
[Musique]
et le dr watson il se fait de plus en
plus rare ces temps-ci
vous savez quand on est marié
quand on est un médecin respectables se
rend ribas kerviler venu ce matin vous
n'étiez pas là il me donnait
l'impression d'un homme assez tourmente
une histoire de chien diabolique
j'avoue que ça ne m'enchante guère c'est
une affaire qui s'annonce difficile
et vous pensez qu'il reviendra killer
basse car il j'en suis sûr non
le docteur watson oui quand j'aurai
besoin de lui
au fait j'ai besoin de lui
mon cher watson
si vous n'avez rien à faire de spécial
et bien j'aimerais que vous veniez me
voir d'urgence
par contre si vous avez quelque chose à
faire de spécial
venez donc quand même c'est élémentaire
madame oleson
[Musique]
on
où
non
[Musique]
bon